do you remember what I told you when I
thought you were the arrow you told me I
saved your life no I did to save yours
people are being murdered your days as
the arrow are finished Lloyd Harper is
in jail
somebody needs to protect this city what
if there's someone else that could go so
it's a team-up high-five
I'm still trying to save you son I don't
need saving I'm gonna break Roy out of
prison
everything I did everything that
happened has led me right here to this
moment
take your rightful place as heir to the
demon fathers gotta kill you it's going
to beg me
and rebirth of violent acts I'm outside
he worried alchool heir to the demon and
you will obey this home he is one away
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 18 video and a
breakdown for the finale trailer they
posted a trailer after the episode just
like they did for flash a lot of you
guys asked me to talk about Stephen
Amell playing Casey Jones in Ninja
Turtles 2 so also say a little something
about that at the end of the video I
think a good log line for arrow right
now is teeny-tiny Ninja Turtle robots of
assassin love just in case you guys
don't want to know anything about that
arrow finale trailer I'm gonna start
with episode 18 stuff first so just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
number 5 Dark Knight Returns police
chase scene arrow itself is informed by
a lot of the visual and thematic cues in
the Dark Knight Returns trilogy and this
is very much like the scene in Dark
Knight Returns when the police were
chasing Batman through the streets as he
was trying to chase down bane bane used
the city as a weapon against Batman
Rachele Ghul is using Starling city as a
weapon against Oliver the funny thing in
all this is that Oliver and Rachel Ghul
seem to be remarkably civil to each
other you also see that because Oliver
is with Roy and Laurel Quentin is a
little reluctant to open fire like he's
not going crazy on him but he ups the
stakes once racial Ghul captures him
monster number 4 Rachel Ghul reveals to
Quentin that Oliver is the arrow my
biggest surprise during the scene is
that Quentin did not know that Sarah was
on the island sometimes it's hard to
keep track of which characters know
which details of Oliver's backstory like
what has happened in the flashbacks who
knows what's going on like the Hong Kong
stuff he just started opening up to
Felicity about Hong Kong in the first
episode of season 3 so there's still
like a lot of stuff that everyone does
not know about him not including his
identity because that was those big WTF
reveal - moving on to number 3 Quentin
reveals that Oliver's the arrow on live
television this reminded me of a very
notable spider-man scene from Marvel's
Civil War event just in case you guys
haven't read that and you don't want
like super spoilers I'm not gonna talk
about it too much let's just let's just
say it has to do with spider-man's
identity being revealed the context of
that moment is very different than
what's going on on arrow but it's a very
similar
type of scene just like the curtain is
pulled up so the real question we need
to ask now is who does not know that
Oliver Queen is the arrow anybody that
wasn't watching television that night or
wasn't on Twitter those are only some
questions that I asked like after the
fact like after I make videos I'm like
you know wouldn't people be twittering
about this in Starling city like even
even like small appearances of the arrow
that people be like holy crap I just saw
the arrow fly by what the hell's going
on people be taking pictures of him on
their cell phones all over the place I
guess it does help that he operates at
night so much and he's always going
through abandoned warehouses not a whole
lot of people hanging out in there that
use Twitter but move against number two
mystery shado identity revealed
so it turns out it's a twin sister and
she also has absolutely no idea what
happened on the island it was a very
touching scene and it's nice seeing the
actress back we really don't know what
her fate is gonna be Oliver just told
her that she couldn't stick around so
what I'm hoping is is that she shows up
again this season or she winds up in
like season 4 like they find a way to
bring her back it'd be really awesome if
they brought her back with a similar
Laurel type arc you know with relation
to the canary where she takes on a
similar persona to shadow and just
becomes his badass fighter
the other big thing about those
flashbacks oh they confirm Amanda Waller
is the one that's been chasing them down
trying to kill them or capture them I'm
really wondering what's going on with
creature commandos and Amanda Waller
right now because he said that Waller
was off doing something else like she
wasn't necessary quote/unquote so I'm
wondering if he's the one that's doing
something Shady
and Amanda Waller even though she's
trying to capture them he's trying to do
something good even though Amanda Waller
runs Argus and tries to protect the
United States she is a very bad person
she's like the dark version of what
Oliver would be if he took over the
League of Assassins and really took on
the racial or persona which looks like
it's going to happen based on the finale
trailer there was a scene of Amanda
Waller in a previous trailer that we
haven't seen yet
so we might see that in episode 19 or 20
or something really really close just to
clarify the finale trailer they posted
tonight is from like the last five
episodes you know probably not a whole
lot of episode 23 stuff in there they're
probably a whole lot of that back but
there is still footage from like the
next one or two episodes that we saw in
previous trailers that we have not seen
yet most notably the appearance of
Amanda Waller here and finally my number
one WTF moment Roy tries to swap himself
for Oliver
turn himself in as the arrow maybe I
should back up a little bit Oliver turns
himself in Felicity's like I hope you
have a good plan I don't even have a
regular plan that was one of my favorite
lines in the episode dad and teeny-tiny
robots which I will also talk about in a
second I know even though it didn't kind
of fit in my top five I agree that we
haven't seen a whole lot of Roy's
emotional art play out on screen like
it's just been in like brief moments
because there's so many characters on
the show they can only focus on so many
at certain times but we get the awesome
Roy sex scene we get that he still wants
to punish himself for killing that cop
last season so it looks like he's trying
to throw himself on his sword to get
Oliver out of jail he's doing it as much
for him as he is for Oliver and team
arrow in this whole situation we also
have to talk about Quentin who has gone
completely bananas something is going to
have to happen to get Roy out of jail
either he's gonna have to die he's gonna
be to be the one that dies or Quentin is
going to have to rationalize it on live
television why he's letting the arrow go
you can't do a press conference like
that where you're like Oliver Queen is
the arrow we're going to arrest him for
crimes against the city without
explaining to everyone why and looking
like a complete fool like he would
probably lose his job if he let the
arrow go so in order for the situation
to resolve itself organically some
really big WTF thing is gonna have to
happen Marc Guggenheim did say that
someone was gonna die in episode 19 he
didn't say who and he didn't say if it
was gonna be a present day or in a
flashback and I still think that Masayo
son's gonna die the only bummer is is
that we're gonna have to wait two weeks
to find out who it is
that's right arrow is on break next week
but then episode 19 is gonna be on the
15th I think whichever Wednesday that is
just as a bonus moment I will talk about
teeny tiny robots I know a lot of you
are asking is that the way that Ray is
going to be able to shrink in the future
I don't know necessarily I think it's
gonna be a backdoor to that there'll be
like a science II explanation for that
nanotechnology is like one backdoor
explanation to that like they could just
pursue that route he is going to STAR
Labs in the next episode of the flash
they're gonna do something to a suit I
don't think it'll be just about
shrinking I think they'll just make it
better in general and then the shrinking
stuff will evolve from that like magic
exists now in the arrowverse because of
the Lazarus Pit then I think it isn't a
huge leap to see Ray Palmer shrinking
that's really the only problem with
arrow it's a little
easier to predict what's going on with
the flash because they're sticking a
little bit closer to the comics arrow
takes a few more liberties with the
characters and plot lines I know a lot
of you guys ask like why that is why
they borrow storylines and characters
from other comics Marc Guggenheim just
said that it's just because most of the
Canon of the arrow comics isn't as broad
as the other characters like when you
look at characters like the flash and
Batman like they just have much much
richer histories hundreds and hundreds
of more issues of comics so those shows
or movies or whatever you know Batman
related stuff they just have more to dig
through Green Arrow himself hasn't ever
really been quite as popular a character
so a lot of his really interesting
stories are from Justice League or like
other characters titles so that's why
I'm totally cool with them borrowing
stuff from other comics just as long as
the story is good really like that's
like the number one order is it an
interesting story here's my big question
for you guys though because you know Roy
is now in this situation and they can't
just let him go how do you think they're
going to resolve that do you think that
Roy is gonna have to die or do you think
that Quentin is going to like come to
some realization and try to rationalize
it to the city and say okay we need the
arrow we have to let him do his thing
those are really like the only two
reasons I can think of to let him go
it's like either we need him so bad that
it doesn't matter what he did and the
damage he caused or he's dead
so we don't need to pursue a case
anymore and that's assuming that Quentin
totally buys that Roy is the arrow he
saw him in the red costume he's like
Harper I see you I know that's you stop
trying to hide Quentin is like so mixed
up in the head it's alright it's hard to
tell what he believes he's going on like
pure emotion right now I would say
though he still thinks Oliver is the
arrow but because everyone else visibly
saw that Roy unmasked himself like he
kind of has to go with that and no point
in that press conference did he tell the
world that the mysterious leader of an
assassin organization told him Oliver's
identity like he can't he can't reveal
racial goal to everyone and just to talk
about like the Ray Palmer Felicity stuff
so yes I know like if you're like an
olicity person you probably love this
episode because Felicity's like oh my
god I love Oliver in case you missed it
too Felicity's mother who you know who's
really awesome she's a really funny
character so I'm always happy when she
comes back tipped us off that Felicity's
father worked with supercomputers so
what I'm really hoping is is that
Felicity's father turns out to be the
season 4 villain because it's supposed
to be like a tech based villain
like a really smart person that would
just be so funny especially after the
mark hamill Darth Vader I am your father
a trickster moment in the flash episode
this week Felicity has like this Empire
Strikes Back Luke Skywalker moment the
funny thing about Felicity's mom in this
episode is that she's kind of like
Felicity's conscious like she just
literally speaks what Felicity is
thinking but never says with exception
to the double entendre 'he's usually
Felicity is the one that brings the
comedy into the episodes like Oliver is
the serious one on Team arrow everyone
else takes it pretty seriously
Felicity is the one that reacts to all
of them like oh my god this is crazy and
like says something funny but this
really was if there ever was a Quentin
based episode this is really as much
about him as it was about Oliver and yes
I do think that at some point he will
slow his roll line and recognize that
there is a greater threat than the arrow
so let's talk about that finale trailer
a whole lot of WTF you know most notably
Rach Oh Mel so let's start with the
fanservice here very clearly Oliver
Felicity gonna get it on even if you're
not an olicity shipper I feel like
you're gonna enjoy that scene that'll be
fun
sort of like a last night before he
becomes Rochelle Goyle kind of thing
most of these scenes look like they're
from Nanda Parbat and this woman here
this mysterious woman that gets a
close-up she has to be an important
person they don't give background
characters big close-ups like this so
she is either
mrs. mother or she's like an older
version of Talia al Ghul based on the
way she's dressed she does look you know
very very much older I think that she's
mrs. mother Nyssa and Talia in the
comics have different mothers so I think
that that's why that's possible they did
say that they were open to bringing
Talia on the show but she would always
be second to Nyssa like they're just
like such big fans of Katrina law
they're backing her any league based
story with a daughter of Ra's al Ghul
will always be with Nyssa but that
doesn't mean that Talia does not exist
it's very much like a to be determined
kind of thing my favorite part of this
trailer though is when Oliver calls
himself all Sahib you must obey me so
let there be no mistake especially given
the flash trailer the flash finale
trailer Oliver
ratio goal is happening the real
question now is is how is he going to
stop being racial goal eventually is it
gonna happen in season four like will
this spill over to next season I know a
lot of you guys are asking me about like
flash time-traveling and resetting
things so that Oliver doesn't end up
becoming racial go at the end of the
I feel like that would be a giant middle
finger to the audience so I feel like if
the flash completely reset the timeline
it'd be like telling us none of the
things that have happened this season on
arrow specifically matter so why would
they film it if it didn't matter why
would they spend millions of dollars
doing this so I don't think the time
travel is going to be the solution to
Oliver being Rachele goal it's more
likely that he'll find some way to
restore Nyssa as the heir so that he can
take back his persona is the heir and go
back to Starling somatically that's
usually what you see in series like this
like something will happen in the
premiere to shake the characters up
completely change the paradigm the
dynamics between the characters and then
by the end of the season everything will
be reset to baseline it's like you take
your toys off the shelf you play with
them then you put them back at the end I
just feel like somatically that would be
a good arc like you start in the
premiere where the characters are at
emotionally and you can like make this
big circle so it's like you know you had
like the funny olicity moment where
Oliver is really happy he's cleaned up
the city he's dating felicity
so like we like slowly come back to that
moment
there have been rumors though that that
in like the last couple of episodes of
arrow we're going to get a teaser for
who the villain is gonna be in season
four so I'm actually really excited
about that they will have a really fun
way of teeing up the big WTF stuff
that'll be happening in season four and
Stephen Amell actually said the things
that he is most excited for fans to see
you know at least after the finales this
year is the season 4 trailer that
they're gonna show at Comic Con this
summer if you guys are big wrestling
fans - Stephen Amell did say he's also
he's gonna go on like WWE Raw at some
point maybe before the end of this year
it sounds like it's gonna happen sooner
rather than later and with respect to
the Ninja Turtle stuff I'm actually
pretty excited Casey Jones you know he
feels like he totally fits in that
universe really he's just treating the
bow and arrow for a hockey stick like
imagine a darker poorer version of
Oliver Queen even though technically
right now Oliver's assets are frozen so
he does have $0 just a quick reminder on
the schedule so air on the flash or on
break next week then the week after that
they both come back so the next episode
of arrow will be episode 19 the next
episode of the flash will be episode 18
the atom crossover so be sure to
subscribe to get those videos in case
you haven't seen it yet I did a
breakdown of the flash trailer and the
flash episode this week you can click
here to watch that and you can click
here to get ready for Marvel's daredevil
which is premiering in a couple weeks -
I'm actually I'm going to the premiere
tonight so I'll probably do like a
non-spoilery review of that tomorrow so
get really excited it's gonna be a lot
of fun everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys soon
you